no cluster foxtrots in this unit am i
right Eric yeah correct so we're taking
a look at Bangalore
you've been playing a lot of Bangalore
she has a passive which is double-time a
tactical which is smoke launcher and ER
ultimate which is Rolling Thunder why
don't we just start with her passive
double time yeah double times awesome
because as long as you're sprinting if
you take any fire at all even if it
doesn't hit you I believe you're always
gonna run even faster which allows you
to get to cover better it allows you to
kind of like reorganize yourself or tell
your team like hey someone's shooting at
me also it's great for like flanking it
also gives you the ability to attack
your opponent right like you're gonna
run even faster so I think as a passive
it's probably one of the bests
and then her smoke launcher which is
probably what you're going to be using
the most
if you play her yeah smoke launcher is
great you get up to two canisters it
allows you to revive your teammates a
little bit safer obviously as the meta
progresses now people are starting to
chuck grenades in there and starting to
just run into the smoke but still it
kind of gives you that cover that makes
it harder for the enemy to kill you
right as you're reviving and also the
smoke canister can be used to disorient
your enemies so one of those strategies
Rob had mentioned is you shoot one at
the enemy you shoot one at yourself so
then they kind of don't know where you
are anymore you can also use it to like
heal yourself you know recharge your
shields sometimes you can use it to like
get across the map when you're trying to
get to a circle to a building because
you need that cover to just make it
harder for the enemy to hit you there's
many applications for the smoke launcher
I would say it even pairs very well with
bloodhound you know because the
bloodhound pops are all you shoot the
canister at them they're disoriented
bloodhound can see exactly where they're
at and they can just shred them yeah I
did that that was me what how I think
another point that you want to talk
about too maybe is visual threat and how
that could work out as well yeah so I
found usually if you find a digital
thread it's good to pass that along to
Banglore because she's in control of the
smoke
therefore if she has that it's easier
for her to see the people in the smoke
because you can fire the smoke at the
other team and then aim that especially
I was using that with a wingman and it
worked pretty well yeah one of my
favorites scopes for the wingman oh for
sure and then another thing I found
useful for the smoke launcher is if a
teammate dies and you're calling them
back in I usually fire smoke at the
respawn beacon and then finally we have
her ultimate Rolling Thunder which I'm
kind of confused when to use exactly
usually I just end up hanging on to it
and forget I have it yeah it's pretty
tough sometimes it's hard for me to use
too but I think some good applications
for it is you know let's say you have a
team that's hiding behind like rocks or
cover throw that at them to kind of get
them out of that cover right because
they know the artillery strike is coming
down they can see the rockets in the
ground and they're like oh crap we can't
stay here anymore because we're gonna
get stunned because this thing also
stuns right it's not as deadly as
gibraltars right yes some stunning as
well yeah it doesn't do as much damage
as gibraltars but it does still do
damage and it
also stuns right and the stun can lead
to death if you're also able to kind of
like charge forward and you know you
feel confident that okay they're gonna
either get hit by this or they're gonna
be out of position because of the
Rolling Thunder then that's a good
application I think I've also used it as
I'm running away sometimes I'm like oh
they're chasing us I'm gonna try to
throw it behind us so that there's
something kind of impeding them wanting
to chase us or they kind of have to go
around it or maybe I'll just freak out
because they see the rockets in the
ground it is kind of like a tougher
ultimate to use that I haven't found
like necessarily the best case for but
those are some of the use cases I've
found more successful yeah and then
moving on to final thoughts I think one
last thing which you did talk about how
bloodhound and and in Bangalore pair
well together but that's also a a
weakness to Bangalore like if another
team has a bloodhound they can use their
vision to see her yeah I've definitely
been lucky enough where I was on the I
was a bloodhound I was like oh you're
trying to revive your teammate I have my
ultimate up thanks for giving me two
kills girl right
I think Bangalore as one of the legends
is one of the most kind of versatile
across-the-board she had for beginners
yeah great kit just across the board she
has a good passive a strong tactical and
a pretty good ultimate well anyway that
is our guide on Bangalore we're gonna
have plenty of these laters so stay
tuned to game spot